being humble I know you are but what did
you say you really single-handedly made
the Iron Man movies of course and it
really kind of
made and made marble you put marble on
the map
would you be upset if they ever replaced
you as Tony Stark and Iron Man or do you
have an exit strategy in any of this I I
believe I do uh let me backtrack and
just say that if you'd asked me in 2008
9 10 how I felt about it I would say
that I was the atlas of the Marvel
Universe I was holding it up well you
were they should erect a shrine in my
honor blah blah blah whatever I really
just got I got to be the the front man
in a band that was going to be in the
Hall of Fame no matter what yes but you
put the franchise on the map had you
[ __ ] it up it could have gone wrong
and that could have been it sure now
look I think everybody winds up for the
most part getting the jobs they're
supposed to get and the rest of it is
sour grapes and why isn't this happening
for me and oh you know I only get the
stuff he turns down it's really kind of
more of a world view and right before
Iron Man and the screen test for that
there was part of me that was saying my
world view has to change if I want to
really have a shot you know if I'm not
on my side for this going my way why
should anybody else be and I'm not
saying that's really what made the
difference but there is a bit of Destiny
involved in a lot of this stuff so you
mean you kind of willed yourself to
change your attitude you said hey I'm
going in for an audition for this movie
I really want Iron Man I'm going in for
favreaux I want to make sure that these
guys and [ __ ] all the other actors and
they're saying I I have to come in here
and make it my part is that what you're
saying you can't be sour grapes you
can't say oh woe is me no I haven't
really done it since but for that one
instant I had to psych myself into that
there was no nobody else on Earth had a
chance I was too prepared I was too
confident was it a great audition in
your opinion I I think yeah obviously it
went pretty well but that's the funny
thing about confidence too is confidence
if you the
the incorrect amount of it and nothing
will ever happen
staying in the pocket with it for a
while only lasts so long you even have
to transcend that because it's still
because everyone goes like oh man you
know you Tony Stark is so confident and
you know you must be that confident and
I'm like I'm portraying someone who's a
very kind of broken guy but his facade
is that he's confident so to say that
I'm just the facade is to kind of
shortchange how human we all are explain
this to me because I'm not an actor and
I don't understand how you develop a
character are you telling me that when
you go in it and it's a comic book you
know it's Tony Stark is this character
right and you can read the comic book
but would you go and study a confident
Tycoon and kind of take on his Persona
is that a way of getting to that
character I was just thinking this is me
and I am in this situation that's what
you do absolutely I am a tycoon I'm
brilliant yeah and how would I behave if
I was that guy I was driving like you
know a beat up used old car there and I
was you know I I had the nicest suit I
had to to put on but I was if you'd
asked me how it arrived that would have
said in a convoy of rolls-royces so
there's nobody this you're not doing an
impression of like a super successful
guy you're not you're not it's not an
impression it's you as an imagining
yourself as a super success yeah in this
instance other times it's it's different
I don't really I don't really have a
method or a process that I use but I
know that when whatever's going to work
for that role or whatever when it hits
me I know it
I love the first Iron Man and I'm not
really a comic book you know fan right
um you know and uh when I but I met with
John Favreau and I wanted to work with
John so badly
um and I got really lucky because I had
someone like John directing that film
and the cast was outrageous you know it
was able to work with Gwyneth yeah I
mean God so exciting it was so exciting
for me it wasn't the same as just going
oh I'm making just any old superhero
movie or whatever that even means I mean
Iron Man was groundbreaking in the fact
that it had a lot of artistic Merit is
being directed by somebody like John
Favreau and you know I have the
opportunity to co-star with Robert but
then at the same time it had this huge
explosive fan reaction and you know who
would have known that Iron Man would
have been the property that would have
is easy to do scenes with because Robert
likes to sort of get extemporaneous and
maybe not stick to the script and as an
actress are you sitting you go wait I
have to have no one to jump in Robert
you got to stick to it a little bit nice
dance with Rob you know Robert's so
playful and it's
oh my gosh it's not it's it's a it's an
absolute pleasure to work with him he's
so so great and and and and responsive
and he's just outrageous when you sign
up to be that character though do you
have to sign away your life to a certain
point because you you have to be
available for all the other you know at
that time I signed away a lot of a lot
of time
um and then later on I was able to kind
of renegotiate my time in it which which
worked out I think in certainly in my
favor but also in Marvel's favor because
they almost it's they kind of prioritize
the work that they do were you freaking
out at first because now that that your
character was so successful do you have
to start turning down things that you
know then you see our big hits and
things like that and movies you might
have liked to make not necessarily no
because I was I was pretty excited to
work on Avengers I mean that was a huge
I mean the cast was enormous and I and I
was able to actually do something with
my character that I only kind of hinted
at in Iron Man 2 so I was do little kids
like bug the [ __ ] out of you now that
you're no
it's more like you know 23 year old guys
that are still you know like hung up on
how you squeeze into that outfit and
everything
you play Hawkeye in The Avengers yeah
and we is it true you were kind of
pissed at first like you got into this
Avengers movie which I think is cool and
being a superhero I think it's great I
was a big comic book reader when I was a
kid I love all these comic book movies I
love seeing it come to life but it was
like as a great actor as you are you
were probably like hey man they're not
giving me any lines here
um you got a little bit aggravated with
this character right well I mean I I
always I always just wanted more you
know it's it's maybe I'm insatiable or
maybe I just want to get out of second
gear if you will it's like well it's
kind of yeah you know it's like it's you
know just use all the gears here there's
something it's like just make it as
interesting as possible and you know
there's a lot of moving parts and a lot
of moving pieces in that giant amazing
world that they've created but it's it's
growing more and more and um you've done
two of those movies right I can't
remember it you did uh uh um two
Avengers
there's a captain man there's a lot of
them maybe it'll be a Hawkeye movie or
something you know what I mean I don't
know that's outside my pay grade when
they came to you did they just come to
you and say look we want you to play
Hawkeye you don't have to audition
anymore I mean for that kind of crap
yeah yeah I think it was kind of like
that yeah yeah do you do you like you
you probably like the first one you
don't even get to be with Robert Downey
Jr like they put me in a [ __ ] scene
with Robert Downey Jr um yeah you know
that was really the main reason why I
wanted to do it because I really liked
what they did with Iron Man and then
they offered this Hawkeye roll which is
a guy that had a
I don't know there's no just a skill set
guy he's not like any superpower I'm
like okay I can I relate to that you
getting in on that Comic-Con action I've
been doing I've been to a few is it
annoying to you no it's actually the one
of the few few times you can kind of uh
interact with fans you know it's it's
actually really nice that's that's nice
yeah yeah as long as they're not you're
doing it in a different way you're not
sitting at a table signing autographs
you're in the room in the question and
answer those are the best parts of the
the Comic Cons yeah yes when you're you
get just have a one not one-on-one but
you're yeah you do these sort of
conferences and get to speak to the fans
and they have questions and you don't
get to sit at a table and charge for
autographs
like little kids The Joy on a little
child's face is you know it's really one
of the most magnetic beautiful sort of
gifts that I've ever been given
um knowing that you know I'm affecting
them in some sort of way you know now
that you're Ant-Man and I'm being
serious do you avoid stepping on ants
like when you're outside do you like
respect ants now yeah I mean like a
weird thing happened
I legitimately won't mess with things
are your allies that's what I I feel
like I do feel this kinship with ants I
was yeah the other day I was like
getting some coffee and and a couple of
them were currently from the sink on the
way to the Keurig machine so what do you
do do you like just pick them up and put
them outside if they're if you could
answer them alone I figure like they
found their way in they'll find their
way out wow that's so beautiful yeah you
really am man
really yeah
lifespan of an ant just how far did you
go with this man I didn't research it
that much but but I was shocked to find
out that you um not only got the part of
Batman but you wrote the screenplay with
another guy right well there was you
know there's a I got this part and this
originally happened because of uh a guy
named Edgar Wright who wrote the script
with another writer and director guy
named Joe Cornish they left the project
Edgar left the the movie and then did
they leave because we're never gonna get
this made it's Ant-Man I mean what was
supposed to go I think it was just they
had different they had he had Edgar had
a different kind of opinion of what it
should be or or how even they work
really how they work right Marvel likes
to try lots of different things and
Edgar sticks you know he's very
particular and specific about what it is
that he wants to shoot and so you know
some of those conversations went on kind
of without me but it was a a pretty
sudden split and then there was another
draft that had been written by somebody
else and then there was this draft that
was kind of floating around we were
going to shoot it in a few months and so
Adam McKay who wrote and directed
Anchorman came on board because we also
needed a director and then uh we wound
up writing the writing the script from
there and then that's what a guy named
Peyton Reed came on to direct it and so
were you guys trying to write it as a
comedy uh well I mean there's something
humorous about Ant-Man yeah but you got
to play it straight right you have to
play it straight it has to fit in there
and the thing is like we thought all
right people will think that it's just
gonna be a straight up comedy which it
really wasn't Marvel kind of they like
it to be funny but then they also wanted
to be dramatic and action and all of
that and so it was it was really we were
trying to kind of cover all those bases
but at the same time you know you do
tell people Ant-Man and he's going to be
flying around on an ant it's not like we
get treated like you know yeah right the
most traumatic thing in the world had
you ever written a script before was
this the first time you actually tackled
something like that I wrote Role Models
right and then I also worked on some of
the scripts of this show party down
right
um and then other things here and there
but uh as far as an actual credited
script this was I think the third maybe
and does the studio trust you because
role models made like 92 million dollars
or something so so is that why they
trust you with this franchise honestly I
have no idea why they would right and I
don't I mean it was all surprising and
it just and it wasn't pitched them on it
I mean
Adam and I Adam and I would go back like
we we would look at we looked at that
script that Edgar had written right and
it never veered that far from it just as
far as the blueprint of it the kind of
the story and then and then we had some
other ideas
Adam and I spent like a couple days
talking about it kind of formulating
this and some new scenes characters and
all that stuff that we went in and
talked to them and said what do you uh
think of this and they said that's great
start writing and so I how long does it
take you to write Ant-Man
um well I always feel like they did
really the heavy lifting so I think that
uh it probably wound up taking us a
couple a couple months a couple of
months yeah but I mean in and out it's
important for an actor to know how to
write right in the sense that now you
know you get you you'll get better Parts
because you have that ability well I
think what's nice about it in my
experience when I've done it is that it
you know I really help it helps me
understand the character I know what the
guy would say because I wrote it yeah
when you're gonna play a superhero and
you got to get ripped who do you go to
to get that training I figured oh if I
get this part Marvel's gonna have their
team and then I don't have to do
anything they didn't do any of that
right and if they have a teammate I
didn't know that yeah there's no show to
money discussing hey we're gonna put you
in training camp and we have a place to
send Superstars I just started like
asking people I knew like what do you do
so what did you do and there I found
like I found this nutritionist right and
also a guy that like worked with some
other athletes and some actors but the
nutritionist probably has you do they
have you eat more calories or less he
just gave me a really specific kind of
eating plan where here's what you have
for breakfast yes he goes here's what
you're gonna have for breakfast you have
like three eggs and some oatmeal and
then also two spoonfuls of this of like
sunflower oil and coconut oil these just
natural oils how intense is the workout
it was crazy you hit the gym like how
many like double sessions every day I
have double sessions really I mean I
would talk to them and they'd say okay
the guy I wound up working out in the
city with this trainer this guy named
Richard who's great right and uh you
know he was a professional bodybuilder
and he would say you know you just need
to work out one time you don't need to
do double sessions we're gonna just
stick to like four or five times a week
but I was also doing other things
outside of that I do kind of cardio on
my own do you run right I would do I
would do different things for cardio
sometimes I would go on like an
elliptical machine other times like one
of those machines that are like the
staircase machine and then jump rope and
Rowing and you had like a six-pack in
the whole thing yeah wow
but it was also a bit of a slow burn
where it's like I was putting in so much
work for so long that after a year I was
like really this is all I get I don't
look like how come I don't look like
Chris Evans right but but you did you
got the physique that was good enough
and I got enough that where it's like I
didn't feel like an imposter in the ant
suit
you work like crazy how do you choose a
film do you uh you probably got a couple
of things a year you got to go through
we got a team uh yeah I got a team of
people um I have an agent a manager you
know all that stuff lawyers and all that
but my agents my managers and I read
scripts together
um but in the end I'm the boss right so
if I like it I tell them you know make a
deal are you one of those guys who uh
does like you know I'll do like a king
kong big picture and then I'll do like
one of those Independent films that'll
probably get me some kind of Academy
Award nominee like do you have a whole
philosophy no do like two big films and
then do a really you know actors film
none of that [ __ ] I do films according
to whether I like them or not and
whether they'll pay you well not
necessarily that whether I like them or
not and what my
schedule is well how do you want one
that's ready is the one that gets done
next right but how do you wind up in
Snakes on a Plane no how do you not wind
up in the same thing again movie I would
have spent my money to go see when I was
a kid I'm looking at that's my criteria
for choosing a movie look at some of
these movies this is something I wanted
to see that I would have gone to see
when I was a kid wow I'm looking at this
coming to America right you were in that
that's the job I had to take is that
well young actor you go to an audition
that's the job you got right you know I
wasn't reading scripts then and choosing
isn't it isn't it funny how some actors
seem to feel like uh you're an actor you
gotta act yeah you're not going to sit
there and be too particular because when
you start out anything you can be and
you you gotta be that's the philosophy
my life gave me tons of [ __ ] about that
all the time so why would you take that
little piddling ass job because it's
because it's paying and it's going to
help pay for Zoe's private school here
in New York and you talk about a little
a little job uh I when I was researching
you I saw you in what happens to be one
of my favorite songs of all time and
I've said this you you were in the
Public Enemy uh 911 you play Flavor
flaves uh Dad yeah that is wild and is
that not one of the greatest rap songs
ever it's awesome it's an awesome song
how do you end up with that gig uh what
was that doing I was I was shooting a
Spike Lee movie and somebody in the
movie was working on the video and it's
the Flavor Flav it needs somebody to
play his dad are you doing anything
tonight right like no like well come on
go up in the Bronx I'm gonna shoot this
video I had no idea what it was but I
just showed up guy walking off a big
alarm clock around his neck and you're
his dad I'm like yeah yeah I'll do it
that's the philosophy when you're an
actor you gotta act you're gonna take a
role and that's it yeah I mean you were
in Exorcist three and yeah they used
somebody else's voice I had two lines
yeah and somebody else's voice why would
they had somebody else no idea did you
ever say to the director why did you
switch out my voice I never saw that guy
yeah nobody cares one of those jobs
where you know I was like number 85 on
the cast list it's a very strange movie
because I remember her when I was flying
to that job I was in first class and I
got bumped out of first class because
Patrick Ewing
right for going down and he needed that
seat and he was he was the angel with
the black wings yeah Patrick Ewing and
fly and Fabio were in that movie no
kidding they were then anxious is three
or no Fabio was in Exodus three yes you
are kidding me oh we were in like
Wilmington North Carolina and some you
know like Drive-In Motel somewhere and
he was always in the lobby standing
under a fan with his hair blowing really
was he possessed in that movie Fabio
Fabio he was Fabio 24 7. oh yeah and all
the little ladies were like losing their
minds you know well I think probably the
two most important directors in your
career Quentin Tarantino of course
because he's giving you so many great
roles and you've you've given him Great
Performances and Spike Lee right
do you think no am I wrong no not
necessarily I mean there are there are
other people I I go George Lucas oh yeah
right Star Wars now what about the
people are critical of the Star Wars you
were in and and does that bug you at all
I mean not that it's your your fault if
someone doesn't like it not at all yeah
but you love being in those films yes I
asked yeah you want it you wanted to be
in you lobbied for that I asked George I
mean I'm gonna I said it I was on a talk
show right and the guy asked me if there
were any directors I want to work with I
go yeah George Lucas I'd love to be in
Star Wars and didn't think anything
about it and then I went off to do uh
sphere and I was in Vallejo which is
close to George's Ranch and somebody
said George wants to meet you yeah so I
went over to talk to him and you know he
was writing episode one saying well I
don't know
you know what I could do but you know I
heard you like my films I'm like look
man
put me in one of those white suits and
let me run across the screen nobody even
needs to know you know I'm just
Stormtrooper nobody even needs to know
you just wanted that experience we'll
find out and you know all of a sudden
months later they called and ended up
being a Jedi yeah and the Marvel films
you like doing those yeah yeah
I got a bunch of superheroes put a bunch
of guys especially if you can tell them
what to do right is it weird though on
the set when they're pretending to be a
superhero it's kind of funny right no no
and they're all dressed up with all the
green screen stuff is really not real
it's supposed to be like that kids game
you played when you were with your
friends right now it's just fun who do
you want to be I want to be Batman who
you want to be I want to be Superman who
you want to be I want to be the flash
you know all of a sudden now you're on
you got your costumes on and you look
good you everything's blowing it's like
hell yeah let's play
foreign